I think that sometimes people may think
that I'm safe or I've been trained to
speak this way I don't know how to be
trained but not on earth with somebody
be training me to speak things Selena
Gomez opening up about her life in and
out of the spotlight in her most candid
interview to date
[Music]
the wolf singer was the first Gaston
coach's new dream at real podcast
released on Wednesday during the
30-minute chat which focused on
authenticity the 26 year old talks about
going to therapy and reveals the one
thing people really don't know about her
I think that a lot of people don't
understand my heart you know and I also
don't I also don't like that it can be
sometimes about appearance - you know
like I don't I don't really appreciate
people judging me on my looks or
anything like that it's great to dress
up and I'm I'm flattered when maybe guys
are like you're pretty I would just love
someone to love me for the person that I
am
Celina also reflected on taking some
time out of the spotlight in 2018 last
year I took a lot of time off I think
that I needed a moment to myself because
I do feel like I was growing and
changing and with all that growing and
changing she revealed the one piece of
advice she would give her younger self I
am a believer of therapy I think that I
have had opportunities where I kind of
reflect on on the younger me and I think
that a lot of the times I wish that I
could hunk myself I wish I could have
done a lot of things and experienced
things maybe a little differently but I
I I go to therapy
polina also explains that therapy helped
her to understand herself and her
childhood quote a lot better now she's
full steam ahead and excited for the
future I am looking forward to my album
whoo and looking forward to spending
time alone oh yes I think I'm finally
finally finally at the
where I love being alone yeah did you
hear that a new album is on its leg but
we got to say Selena is already killing
it in 2019
she joined cardi B on stage at Coachella
to perform their collab with DJ snake
and ozuna taki taki selena is set to
appear at we Day on Thursday in LA
along with Neil Patrick Harris Natalie
Portman Meghan Trainor Hailee Steinfeld
chance the rapper Joe Jonas and more
Selena revealed that she was ready to
step back into the spotlight for a good
cause
releasing a statement that read in part
quote every year we day leaves me
feeling inspired and hopeful the youth
have an incredible positive and
passionate attitude for making real
change in the world
eg was with Selena at we Day in 2017 I'm
just more here to encourage these kids
and to tell stories with them because
there's nothing more beautiful than
seeing all these kids that are here
today actually earns being here they
wanted to get back to their community
they want to inspire other kids to do
the same so I'm just here to to be a
part of it you know
god I love Selena and I'm so excited for
her new album something tells me that
this one is gonna be her best and most
honest one yet and of course we'll be
here to keep you up to date on all
things Selena so be sure to subscribe to
all things et until next time I'm Holly
Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]